الديون الطبية هي مشكلة كبيرة
هنا في الولايات المتحدة
، ثلثا الأفراد الذين
أفلسوا العام الماضي
أفلسوا بسبب الديون الطبية. أنا
جراح
بدأت في سماع قصص عن المرضى
الذين
كانوا يعانون من أعباء
مالية لا أستطيع فهمها و  ربما
ساعدتهم
في آلامهم أو ربما تمكنت من
مساعدتهم على المشي مرة أخرى
أو العودة إلى الحياة الطبيعية ، لكن بعد
ذلك اكتشفت أن
بعض هؤلاء المرضى كانوا يعانون من
ضغوط مالية هائلة
شعرت بالعجز ، أدركت
أنني بحاجة لمحاولة ذلك  جعل الأمور مختلفة ، لقد
كنت في سلاح الجو لمدة 21
عامًا تقريبًا بين خدمتي النشطة
ووقتي الاحتياطي ، أجرينا الكثير من
العمليات الجراحية في أفغانستان
وجراحة إنسانية إلى حد كبير ، كانت حوالي 95 حالة
من تلك الحالات التي قمنا
بها لمساعدة المدنيين
الآن أنا وفريقي  للقيام بهذه المهمة الطبية
هنا في الفناء الخلفي الخاص بنا ، فإن برنامج m25
هو آلية نسمح من خلالها
للمرضى بالاستثمار
في أنفسهم الآن ماذا نعني
بذلك المريض  يأتون ويقولون
جيدًا أنني لا أستطيع تحمل
الأثر المالي للجراحة ، لذلك
نقدم لهم الفرصة للتطوع
بوقتهم في منظمة خيرية
، كما يتيح لهم الفرصة
لتجنيد الأصدقاء والعائلة
والجيران وحتى الأشخاص الذين لم يلتقوا بهم من قبل
قبل مساعدتهم
في إنجاز ساعات التطوع
بهذه الطريقة ،
نساعد في رعاية المرضى الذين
نساعدهم في رعاية المجتمع
الذي لدينا جيران يساعدون الجيران
[موسيقى
] أعاني من اعتلال الأعصاب وهو
ضغط الأعصاب
في أسفل ساقك و  قدمي اليمنى
أشعر وكأنها نائمة طوال الوقت
، دائمًا ما تكون السلالم هي الجزء الصعب ، يمكنني
أن أسقط بسهولة
، أخبرني أنها 560 ساعة خدمة مجتمعية ،
جيف
ألف دولار لم يكن ممكنًا ،
لدي عمل صغير ،
لذا فأنت تعلم أن شخصًا آخر يجب أن يكون
في حالة مرضية ، لا يزال لديهم شيك راتب
في نهاية اليوم ،
فأنا لا أفعل إذا لم يكن هذا خيارًا ،
ربما كنت سأقول
جيدًا أننا سنتعامل معه ونوفر المال
حتى  يمكنني دفع ثمنها ، لقد
رأيت مقطع فيديو على فيسبوك للدكتور أغويلا يروي فيه
جيف
قصته وكيف انخرط في برنامج m25 ،
فكرت على الفور في
طلاب التمريض هنا في
المركز الطبي بجامعة نبراسكا
، ولذا اعتقدت أنه سيكون الأفضل
مناسبًا لمشروع خدمة المجتمع الخاص بنا ،
لقد قدمنا ما يقرب من 180 ساعة من خد
ة المجتمع بشكل جم
عي تجاه جراحة السيد جنسن ، ول
يعرف شخص واحد في برنامج التمريض هذا من كن
، بل
ان لطف الغرباء الذي أن
ز هذا الأمر بالنسبة لي ، فه
يحظون بالدعم المعنوي من مجتمعهم  لمساعدتهم
على التحسن وهذا يغير
الطريقة التي
يتابع بها المرضى رعايتهم الصحية ، من الصعب
إحداث فرق
إذا لم تحاول تعطيل الوضع
الراهن ، حيث يعمل برنامج m25 على
تمكين المرضى الذين غالبًا ما يشعرون بأنهم
ضحايا النظام
في بلدي.  كان لدي هذا الأمل في قلوب
جيراننا وفي أنفسنا إحساس التطوع